salut et s'il était une perversion je
serai quoi comme derrière soi
ils abreuvaient oui la version pas tu
serais pédéraste haut du range derrière
c'est pas une version pc irma ou pour
mourir idiot s'est pas très bien passé
un battant qui était actif ça allait me
gioia était pas si je sais pas moi j'ai
du cédant dans libération je n'ai pas
inventé ça c'est pas vrai c'est pour moi
qui pars en terre qui borde et laurine
avancer ce que tu disais pourtant dans
le journal d'accord c'est pas vrai ah
d'accord
tu serais zoophile
dans le même numéro 10 ah bah oui non
mais attends dit des trucs mon pote va
assumer après c'est marrant tu disais
quand tu étais petit avait fait des
choses une petite chienne
après tout s'enchaîne mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas vrai il est rangé des
voitures avec ton petit loi s'est bien
passé et n'est content tati tiennent
toujours important tu l'oubliés je sais
pas coprophages quand même
alors je suis mon magazine ont été
guéris
ouais enfin gamin je nomme je ferai
jamais ça gueule ça toi bats ici n'y
avait pas de là les petits pognon ouais
alors il va dans le bon sens et y avait
un vrai lit
je pointe du combat aux mains
2pac you'll pour moi si tu vas futur
ils étaient déjà tous selon
et puis de vous mettre là que la hotte
ya deux plus de l'exploiter rien
vous tirez à l'oeil nu j'ai un jour il
rentre et il se sent la merde ici dit
bah écoute on va dire l'embase piteux
juin session
mais dans ce cas il y en a qui y en a
qui en bouche mais alors on a tellement
de demandes on peut pas assurer on met
au frigo réchauffe au bain marie qu'elle
perd pied
bienvenue mais allaoui et en surprises
dans les culs ces scientifiques chinois
c'est comme lancer parfait suédois est
le petit plus c'est une loi divine et
aller plus haut